Mathieu évidemment vous restez avec moi
parce que j'ouvre notre second débat
vous le savez on choisit volontairement
le plus souvent possible décalé de de
l'actualité des bas de société
consacrées ce soir ou cyberattaque des
hôpitaux aux entreprises en passant par
la guerre en Ukraine et le son de plus
en plus nombreuses de plus en plus
coûteux avant de donner la parole à nos
experts sur ce sujet le reportage de la
rédaction de Public Sénat mathiasaraez
et hémo Touré se sont rendus en
Seine-Saint-Denis ou une dizaine de
communes c'est une communauté de
communes était attaquée en décembre
dernier rançon réclamé 4 millions
d'euros regardez
lundi 6 décembre 2021 fredjellal vient
comme tous les jours travailler au
syndicat des systèmes d'information de
Bobigny ce chef de projet informatique
constate ce matin-là qu'il ne peut se
connecter qu'à ses mails l'interface en
ligne lui refuse ses droits
se dysfonctionnement
m'a pas plu alerté que cela puisque j'ai
pas accès on va dire à ce qui se passe
derrière les la machine derrière les
serveurs mais vers 9h très rapidement
mes collègues ont constaté effectivement
des anomalies qui ont justifié l'arrêt
des serveurs et l'arrêt de l'ensemble
des services de la structure la
structure qui gère les outils comptables
mais aussi de logements sociaux de paye
de plus de 8000 agents d'une dizaine de
communes de Seine-Saint-Denis et victime
d'une cyber-attaque seule solution pour
tenter de continuer la marche travailler
en mode local c'est-à-dire rapatrier
physiquement tous les services au siège
du syndicat l'ensemble de l'application
serait installée sur un ordinateur qui
pourrait avoir en mode sécurisé à la
base de données pour pouvoir restituer
les informations pour pouvoir effectuer
les opérations courantes l'attaquer
d'une ampleur sans pareil pour la
structure des agents se relaient jour et
nuit sur le site pendant plusieurs
semaines au total il faudra deux mois
pour un retour complet à la normale où
nous sommes des cibles intéressantes
parce que nous gérons beaucoup de choses
nous gérons donc beaucoup de données
pour nos pour les administrer et pour
les collectivités on nous a quand même
demandé et c'est de l'autorité publique
une une
rançon de 4 millions d'euros que nous
avons refusé de payer nous en font un
pas d'honneur en disant que c'est une
structure publique et aujourd'hui on le
négocie pas et on ne paiera pas de
rançon les cyberattaques se font de plus
en plus fréquentes elles ont augmenté en
moyenne de plus de 30% entre 2020 et
2021 pour s'en protéger les
professionnels du secteur préconisent la
prévention avec des systèmes performants
de détection basé typiquement comme ce
que autour de system avec de
l'intelligence artificielle et ce qu'on
appelle du machine learning pour pouvoir
détecter la présence d'un attaquant qui
ne fait rien qui fait que repérer le
réseau mais qui est quand même perturbe
en étant présent le mode de
fonctionnement du réseau 6 mois après
l'attaque le syndical assure les leçons
ont été tirées un Livre Blanc devrait
prochainement être publié pour partager
cette expérience avec d'autres
collectivités
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Christine Dubois Clément bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes chercheur pour la
chair risque et pour l'observateur de
l'intelligence à l'Université Paris un
Nicolas arpaji en bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi directeur de la stratégie en
cybersécurité de train de micro hauteur
de la cybersécurité la collection que
sais-je aux éditions presse
universitaires de France Thomas Huchon
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi journée
des investigations spécialiste du
numérique auteur de anti fake news
coécrit avec Jean-Bernard Schmitt c'est
aux éditions First j'accueille également
complexe en visioconférence Damien
bancal qui est spécialiste en cyber
intelligence et fondateur de zatase.com
bonsoir à vous bienvenue et Mathieu
croissanto est resté évidemment à mes
côtés un chiffre tient pour commencer on
reste sur puisqu'on avait on était en
reportage en Seine-Saint-Denis sur ses
communes attaquées sur les cibles
publics une attaque sur 3 dirigée contre
un établissement public ou une
collectivité territoriale en France en
2022 et alors là je disais on cherche
des thèmes qui sont déconnectés de
l'actualité sauf que quand on parle
cyberattaque de toute façon l'actualité
nous rattrape parce qu'il y en a
tellement souvent c'est tombé
aujourd'hui le département de la
Seine-Maritime qui a été touchée à son
tour par une attaque informatique
d'ampleur elle a dû provisoirement
couper complètement ces réseaux est-ce
que les établissements publics Christine
du goin Clément sont moins bien protégés
ou pas d'ailleurs peut-être
alors il y a eu une augmentation de la
vulnérabilité pour beaucoup des des
établissements publics pour plusieurs
raisons et qui avaient démarré notamment
avec le télétravail parce que dans
l'urgence on a dû mettre des postes à
distance sans forcément avoir le temps
de mettre en place les systèmes de
sécurité il y a Ferrand et puis il y a
certaines structures on pourrait
notamment parler des hôpitaux dont la
priorité et ben c'est de soigner le
patient et c'est pas forcément d'avoir
un si qui soit performant ou qui soit ne
serait-ce que en service informatique et
qui soit ne serait-ce que harmoniser
permettant d'avoir une une meilleure
prise en compte de l'ensemble de la
sécurité alors il y a beaucoup d'efforts
qui ont été qui ont été faits mais à
chaque fois que de toute façon vous
allez essayer d'améliorer le système et
bien vous allez améliorer on prend en
parallèle les principes d'attaque
sachant qu'il y a plusieurs types
d'attaques et certaines sont des
mutations de crimes de criminalité si
vous voulez du monde of line et
classique à un monde online avec par
raison d'opportunités dans certains cas
Nicolas Arpajon que cherche les les
pirates ou les délinquants ou les crimin
informatique parce que le mot pirate il
est un peu il a un petit côté je sais
pas romantique
par exemple sur la sur la scène maritime
sur la scène maritime qu'est-ce qui
cherche il cherche les données
personnelles des habitants un
département c'est enfin une collectivité
publique c'est détenteur de données
personnelles c'est-à-dire d'état civil
de donner financières puisque il s'avère
que le département après va pouvoir
jouer
présenter des prestations sociales ce
sont des données qui sont réelles
nombreuses à jour et qui ne sont pas
substituables c'est à dire que c'est
vraiment votre vrai nom votre vrai date
de naissance votre vrai email votre
numéro de téléphone donc sur les
informations de valeur parce qu'elles
sont exploitables les données
personnelles font partie des
informations qui sont le plus
monétisable pourquoi parce que il y a
des places de marché où on va pouvoir
ainsi faire fructifier ce type
d'information pour conduire soit des
opérations d'usurpation d'identité et
puis éventuellement pour documenter des
prises de contact
ultérieure d'ailleurs au palais de
l'hôpital de Corbeil l'hôpital de
Corbeil a été obligé ces derniers jours
d'envoyer plusieurs centaines de
courriers c'est la législation qui pour
prévenir les titulaires toutes les
personnes qui ont été en interaction qui
ont eu un dossier soit en tant qu'agent
soit en tant que patient de
l'établissement pour leur dire voilà vos
données ont été piratées donc soyez
vigilant dans les semaines les mois à
venir si d'aventure vous receviez des
messages qui feraient référence à des
éléments qui sont présents dans nos
bases de données et donc qui pourraient
servir aux pirates pour crédibiliser
leurs messages malveillants et donc la
la réponse qu'on a trouvé c'est
d'imposer au gestionnaires des données
le fait d'informer les titulaires des
données donc les femmes les hommes qui
sont concernés de manière à être
vigilants et on voit bien que c'est donc
une réaction très humaine face à des
attaques qui elles sont numérisées j'ai
une question pour bien comprendre pour
le téléspectateurs ça se revend à des
escrocs
c'est à dire que pour ça que d'ailleurs
l'hôpital n'est pas l'hôpital public au
terme crapule n'est pas un client une
cible intéressante pourquoi parce que
déjà il y a une doctrine une doctrine de
l'État français qui demande aux
établissements publics de ne pas payer
les rangs sont donc déjà le par principe
ensuite et là les établissements publics
de santé sont souvent comment dire un
pécunieux et donc ne pas forcément les
ressources et s'il fallait au début de
l'hôpital de Corbeil c'était 10 millions
d'euros il n'a pas 10 demander au départ
c'est initialement qui est descendu
puisque c'est une évolution de ce mode
opératoire de ces derniers mois il y a
des phases de négociation avant c'était
un prix à prendre ou à laisser
aujourd'hui il y a des phases de
négociation donc là dans le cadre de
l'hôpital de Corbeil on est descendu à
un million l'équivalent en crypto
monnaie d'un million d'euros mais comme
un la règle est de toujours de pas payer
pour les établissements publics et deux
que de toute façon même le million le
sortir en cage d'une comptabilité
publique ça paraît assez compliqué donc
c'est pas des cibles intéressantes
lucratives d'un point de vue de de
d'organisation juste après je fais un
premier tour de table Thomas Huchon
quand tes gamins c'est un film de
science-fiction ça y est on est dans
dans l'air du danger technologique quoi
c'est moi j'ai grandi effectivement dans
les années 90 on est prêt disait l'an
2000 avec des attaques informatives
beaucoup plus jeune que moi beaucoup
beaucoup
mais en fait bah oui qui pédia donnera
la réponse vous savez c'est le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que nous sommes
transparents même quand nous ne voulons
pas moi j'ai grandi dans avec l'idée
qu'effectivement l'an 2000 ça serait des
problèmes informatiques et des voitures
qui volent on n'a pas les voitures qui
volent mais on a visiblement quand même
des problèmes informatiques je crois que
ce qui est très intéressant en fait dans
cette ce nouvel enjeu qui nous est posée
c'est à la fois d'arriver à maintenir le
monde d'avant c'est à dire conserver des
choses comme la vie privée le le que ce
qui nous appartient continuez à nous
appartenir et en même temps d'exister
dans un monde où la technologie a pris
énormément d'espace et donc je crois
qu'on va pas pouvoir faire l'économie et
bien d'apprendre comment tout ça
fonctionne parce qu'en réalité les
pirates informatiques ils arrivent à
nous arnaquer parce qu'on comprend rien
à ce qui se passe derrière nos écrans on
comprend rien à ce qui se passe derrière
nos téléphones on comprend rien à ces
questions de données personnelles et je
le dis avec d'autant plus de force que
nous sommes dans un palais de la
République et que j'ai bien peur que les
sénateurs pour qui j'ai pourtant une
grande estime et bien comprenne par
exemple ces problématiques qui sont
essentielles le principal problème qu'on
a aujourd'hui c'est que ceux qui
devraient nous protéger ne comprennent
pas le problème et donc ne peuvent pas
trouver alors ça pose la question de ce
que font les législateurs de ce que fait
le gouvernement pour lutter contre la
cybersécurité je propose à Samia de chir
de nous de nous rejoindre rebonsoir
Samia merci d'être là pour pour ce
second débat donc avec une loi qui sera
examinée à partir de demain justement
ici au Sénart
la loi d'orientation et de programmation
du ministère de l'intérieur c'est un
texte important puisqu'il trace la
feuille de route du ministère pour les 5
prochaines années et ils prévoient rien
de moins qu'une révolution cop
contiennent dans la lutte contre la
cybercriminalité ce sont les mots du
gouvernement qui veut en faire un axe
central de sa politique sécuritaire
parce que cette cybercriminalité elle a
pris une ampleur considérable d'après
les chiffres de l'exécutif elle
progresse de 10 à 20% par an on estime
aujourd'hui que deux tiers des
escroquerie sont liés à Internet et
qu'une entreprise sur cinq a déjà été
victime d'une cyberatax ce qui fait dire
à Gérald Darmanin qu'en matière de
délinquance il n'y a tout simplement
plus vraiment de frontières entre le
monde réel et le monde numérique on
écoute tout de suite un extrait de son
audition au Sénat le 21 septembre
dernier les ventes se font en grande
partie désormais sur Internet la vente
de drogue suberise y compris les
atteintes aux mineurs se font sur le
Dark Web avec des choses
particulièrement ignobles qui se font
désormais dans le monde physique avec
par exemple des viols commandés à
distance et qui est sur lequel la police
et c'est des gendarmerie doit désormais
se prendre autrement pour lutter contre
la pédophilie bref on regarde
l'intégralité ou la quasi intégralité
des faits de délinquance qui existaient
dans le monde réel il migre tout ou
partie dans le monde numérique et il
faut que la voiture numérique ou
technologique du policier ou du gendarme
aille aussi vite que la voiture
technologique des voleurs ou des
délinquants et que propose Gérald
Darmanin pour que la voiture numérique
des policiers des gendarmes aille plus
vite ou aussi vite que celle des voleurs
alors il propose d'abord de former plus
de policiers plus de gendarmes elle a
lutte contre la cybercriminalité avec
notamment le recrutement de 1500 cyber
patrouilleurs d'ici la fin du
quinquennat le gouvernement veut aussi
faciliter la saisie d'urgence des crypto
actifs c'est à dire les crypto monnaie
de type Bitcoin parce qu'aujourd'hui la
police elle peut saisir très rapidement
de l'argent sur un compte bancaire ou
des biens matériels mais c'est beaucoup
plus difficile de faire ça dans
l'urgence pour saisir des crypto monnaie
alors ces crypto monnaie c'est
précisément la monnaie des chances
d'échange pardon qui est utilisé dans le
des rançons et puis justement pour ce
qui est du paiement de ces rançons une
des nouveautés que propose le
gouvernement c'est que pour être
remboursé par le rassurance et bien les
entreprises qui ont payé là rançon
devront désormais porter plainte pour
être remboursé tout ça pour avoir une
meilleure remontée des informations aux
forces de l'ordre puisque si elle ne
savent pas exactement combien il est
d'attaque et bien ils ne peuvent pas
agir en conséquence ça coûte combien
quand même le gouvernement mais sur la
table financez-nous ça alors ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'il y a une enveloppe de 15
milliards d'euros pour la locmi ce que
je disais tout à l'heure la loi
d'orientation et programmation ministère
de l'Intérieur et que sur cette
enveloppe de 15 milliards d'euros il y a
7 milliards d'euros qui sont réservés à
la transformation numérique donc à peu
près la moitié de la somme sauf que la
transformation numérique c'est pas
seulement la lutte contre la
cybercriminalité c'est aussi par exemple
toute la transition numérique des
procédures de police qui est prévue dans
cette loi et il y a beaucoup de travail
toute la modernisation du secteur et à
aucun moment dans son projet de loi le
gouvernement ne précise quel enveloppe
il bien plus précisément à la
cybercriminalité et c'est d'ailleurs à
demi-molo le reproche que fait le
Conseil d'État sur cette loi dans un
avis qui l'a rendu sur le projet de loi
merci Samia dechir pour toutes ces
précisions Damien bancal je vous ai pas
encore donné la parole dans ce si on
reprend le l'image du ministre de
l'Intérieur la voiture numérique des
policiers des gendarmes peut-elle aller
plus vite que celle des des voleurs il y
a est-ce qu'on n'a pas toujours un une
technologie ou
ou un levier de retard quoi vous voyez
ce que je veux dire on l'aura toujours
pourquoi parce que les pirates
informatiques ils travaillent 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7 ils ont pas de
congé ils ont pas de pause ils ont pas
de RTT eux leur mission c'est le gros
bateau de pêche il lance leur filet tout
ce qui leur tombera dedans va leur
servir à des escroqueries à des
tentatives de chantage à des piratages
ils auront malheureusement toujours
cette petite longueur d'avance
maintenant notre mission est plutôt de
leur mettre un maximum de bâtons dans
les roues
c'est dommage mais qu'ils aillent
regarder ailleurs on parlait des
établissements publics pour démarrer
évidemment ça fait le lien aussi avec
avec l'action du gouvernement mais
quand un hôpital est attaqué on évoquait
le fait que il n'avait pas forcément les
moyens de payer la rançon il a pas
forcément non plus les moyens de
s'équiper en matériel informatique on va
dire le plus récent est-ce que c'est
encore une réalité ça aujourd'hui c'est
une réalité mais il y a une autre
réalité c'est que moi je croise de plus
en plus de professionnels de la sécurité
informatique et de l'informatique dans
les centres hospitaliers qui sont des
passionnés et qui travaillent avec les
budgets qui leur sont alloués sauf qu'en
face qu'on le veuille ou non c'est
pirates informatiques vont chercher vont
essayer de trouver la porte d'entrée qui
leur permettra de lancer des
malveillances et quelles qu'elles soient
il faut savoir que moi depuis 30 ans que
je suis sage je vois une véritable
progression mais c'est au petit bonheur
la chance ça va être l'occasion qui fait
de la ronde tiens il y a une faille
dernièrement il y a une grosse faille
qui est dédiée un grand professionnel de
du logiciel et bien ils ont trouvé cette
porte d'accès mais il y a aussi l'autre
porte d'accès qui est l'humain bref eux
leur travail et aujourd'hui on peut
vraiment clairement parler d'entreprise
de la malveillance leur travail c'est de
trouver cette porte d'entrée donc c'est
un business on l'a bien compris la
France 4e pays le plus touché par les
cyberattaques selon watch gold qui est
un éditeur de logiciel États-Unis en 1
Angleterre en deux Allemagne en 3 et
France en quatre Christine Dubois
Clément on a toujours une un métro de
retard peut-être pas la meilleure
expression mais enfin c'est ce que c'est
ce que on évoquait à l'instant c'est
quoi c'est pas un arsenal législatif
dont on a besoin ou est-ce que c'est
effectivement des moyens alors disait on
n'arrive pas à chiffrer finalement
quelle part de ce de ces 15 milliards
vont aller vraiment à la lutte contre
les cyberattaques alors il y a plusieurs
choses effectivement donc dans la masse
qui est donnée qu'est-ce qui sera
effectivement dédié à de la
cybersécurité ou pas il y a aussi autre
chose à mon avis sur lequel il faut
qu'on revienne c'est et on tous se dit
en filigrane c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où vous allez attaquer une
structure dont vous savez qu'elle n'a
pas les moyens et pas la capacité
technique non plus de payer parce que je
pense pas qu'on est beaucoup de
gestionnaires d'hôpitaux qui est des
Wallet en Bitcoin ou en hétérum et qui
soit quand bien même ils le voudrait en
capacité d'aller régler en Bitcoin
l'architecture qui vous permet de payer
en cryptoïde je pense pas qu'on les aie
et quand bien même il le faudrait le
temps que on remonte un dossier qu'on le
fasse c'est très compliqué
parce que c'est on l'a dit c'est de la
criminalité c'est de l'offre et de la
demande or les données personnelles ont
une véritable valeur que vous allez
pouvoir revendre sur des plateformes
qu'on va retrouver sur des groupes qui
sont en règle générale qui font
l'intérêt des services de sécurité si
vous voulez et qui vont permettre de
faire de l'usurpation d'identité à plus
ou moins grands titres c'est à dire que
et bien vous pouvez apprendre à un
moment ou un autre que vous avez
souscrit un prêt pour tel ou tel endroit
que vous allez récupérer
des
prescriptions médicales par exemple des
produits ce genre de choses et ça un
couple si vous voulez complet numéro de
sécurité sociale en plus en règle
générale il y a les données bancaires ou
autre à une valeur beaucoup plus
importante que simplement alors les
cours varient les cours varient et
là-dessus il y a énormément énormément
de chiffres différents mais les
estimations les plus hautes que que l'on
avait pu voir au grand moment du pic de
riuk donc qui était un rançongiciel qui
avait beaucoup attaqué les hôpitaux et
les systèmes médicaux on était entre
deux 300 dollars pour un dossier médical
complet ce qui est colossal c'était les
estimations attention les plus hautes
donc d'autres vous estimez ça à autour
de 80 dollars ce qui était donc là aussi
on a que c'est vrai
ou des dizaines de milliers de fois
alors vous avez ça c'est là que l'argent
rentre quoi vous allez pouvoir avoir ça
et puis il y a aussi une autre une autre
méthode alors par exemple il y avait une
clinique qui a été spécialisée dans tout
ce qui était opération de chirurgie
esthétique qui avait été hackée à
Londres et interrogé esthétique
notamment de stars du show business et
ben alors là ce que vous allez avoir
c'est la capacité de faire et bien tout
simplement du chantage en disant bah
est-ce que vous voulez absolument savoir
quels sont les opérations que vous avez
pu subir vous allez retrouver le même
dans le milieu économique vous avez pas
envie quand par exemple vous êtes le
patron d'une grande entreprise qui
s'apprête à faire une fusion acquisition
qu'on puisse faire sortir que vous avez
des problèmes de santé par exemple sur
ce genre de choses donc il y a la
capacité d'utilisation de revente tout
simplement pour récupérer des identités
vous allez avoir tout ce que vous pouvez
avoir sur du chantage et alors qu'ils
sont évidemment des pratiques
criminelles donc si vous voulez il y a
quand vous allez prendre un hôpital
sortie du fait qu'il vous réponde ou pas
bien il y a tout le bénéfice que vous
allez pouvoir en tirer et
malheureusement c'est la question de
l'offre et de la demande alors c'est
bien qu'il y a des acheteurs de
l'hôpital je vous pose deux témoignages
d'abord parce que il y a d'abord
l'impact de la de la cyberattaque sur le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital alors là on
revient à ce dont on parlait tout à
l'heure c'est à dire la taxe sur
l'hôpital de Corbeil-Essonnes c'était le
21 août dernier écoutez la coordinatrice
générale des soins de cet hôpital les
écrans étaient noirs les
urgentistes ne savaient même plus quel
patient ils avaient dans les lits et il
ne savait plus qu'elle prise en charge
il y avait donc fallait absolument qu'on
sécurise les soins donc ça c'est
l'impact très réel sur les risques de
perte de chance dans le milieu médical
donc ça c'est une réalité et puis à ce
que vous évoquez c'est à dire
l'utilisation à posteriori de ces
données de santé donner personnelle les
plus intimes et là je vous propose
d'entendre ce que dit le directeur
général de l'Agence nationale de la
sécurité des systèmes d'information
Guillaume Poupard et donner en quantité
assez massive des données personnelles
de santé de personnes qui ont été
soignées à l'hôpital ont été diffusés
c'est parfaitement abject il y a pas de
doute là-dessus parce que ça rentre dans
l'intimité tout un chacun et au-delà de
ce côté objet avec tes choquant ça ouvre
la possibilité pour plein d'escrocs de
conduire d'autres formes d'attaque
vis-à-vis de ces personnes là quand vous
connaissez finalement l'intimité de
quelqu'un c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'aller l'arnaquer si vous recevez un
courrier de gens que vous connaissez pas
qui vous demandent de l'argent
normalement vous répondez pas
si vous recevez un courrier avec les
bonnes en-têtes avec le nom de votre
médecin traitant avec des détails très
précis sur votre passé médical et qui
vous dit qu'il faut payer quelques
centaines d'euros pour régler une
facture liée à une intervention à
l'hôpital là vous avez toutes les
chances de vous faire avoir Thomas
Huchon vous parliez de l'impossibilité
finalement de ne pas être de ne pas être
en exposition permanente dans nos vies
d'aujourd'hui ça y participe d'une
certaine façon je crois qu'en fait on a
on a assisté quelque part une forme de
de changement de civilisation sans s'en
rendre compte au cours des 20 dernières
années finalement on nous parle beaucoup
pour expliquer notre époque de la Poste
vérité un posthroof en anglais comme si
c'était le à ce qui caractériserait dans
tes potes un certain nombre de
spécialistes notamment Michel cosinski
qu'un des plus grands spécialistes
mondiaux sur ces questions données
personnelles j'ai vu l'occasion de
rencontrer il m'avait dit en fait avec
ton poste vérité tu as rien compris
l'époque c'est post privé c'est la fin
de la vie privée et tant qu'on arrivera
pas à comprendre et donc à réguler ce
nouvel espace où la vie privée à quelque
part disparu et ben on n'arrivera pas à
solutionner les problèmes qui sont face
à nous je vois que Nicolas n'est pas
totalement d'accord mais c'était Machu
cabin qui est effectivement avait dit la
vérité la vie privée caduque le principe
était suspect parce que évidemment quand
le modèle économique de votre
organisation est fondée précisément sur
l'exploitation de cette ce matériau ce
que disait le patron de Facebook
il va falloir considérer que en tout cas
il faut une conscience et là par contre
je reprends ce que disait Thomas au
début c'est que même si nous n'avons pas
tous vocation à nous transformer en
juriste ou tous nous transformer en
ingénieur en informatique il est
important de hausser notre niveau de
connaissance nous sommes tous à nos
Numericus c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui va
avoir sa vie quotidienne sa vie
professionnelle sa vie personnelle que
vos habits sentimentale ou médical
façonnés par ce monde numérique et donc
plus on en comprendra les modalités les
risques et éventuellement les préc à
prendre plus on sera renforcé éduqué et
ça c'est quand même un élément de
l'autonomie du citoyen face à ces sujets
c'est effectivement l'un des problèmes
auxquels on est confronté aujourd'hui
c'est que encore une fois on ne comprend
pas et je crois que pour les futurs
générations ça serait leur faire un bien
mauvais tour que de ne pas leur
enseigner tout cela et je crois qu'il y
a il y a deux enjeux sur l'espace
numérique il y a la question de la
désinformation il faut qu'on apprenne
tous vu qu'on veut tous un peu devenir
des journalistes sur les réseaux sociaux
à vérifier un peu tout ça c'est-à-dire
qu'on peut plus faire l'économie de ça
et bien sur les questions de données
personnelles de sécurité informatique on
se retrouve un petit peu dans la même
situation on a besoin de monter en gamme
de monter en niveau de connaissance
sinon les conséquences pourraient
vraiment être Matthieu ce qui me frappe
c'est que il y a donc un problème
culturel sociétal j'allais dire et ce
qui est pas un problème politique aussi
du point de vue pouvoir public je parle
pas d'un parti d'un autre mais quand on
voit la façon dont la France embrasse
euh cette révolution numérique cette
transition numérique on a un secrétaire
d'État c'est pas lui faire un jure qui
qui qui n'a pas l'air d'avoir une
transversalité c'est c'est pas mis au
même rang que la transition écologique
par exemple or c'est quelque chose qui
bouleverse son avantagement nos modes de
vie et l'État paraît toujours avoir un
coup de retard moi je regarde ça de
l'extérieur mais on a eu la crise du
coïd ou un jeune ingénieur a réussi à
faire coïtracker pour où on pouvait
savoir où on pouvait se faire vacciner
parce que l'État était un fichu de le
faire or le garçon en question le
faisait à partir d'exploitation de
données publiques de ce que j'ai compris
là on lance une un site internet ecoweb
pour mesurer la consommation d'énergie
mais l'État est pas fichu de faire une
application il se trouve que c'est ce
même garçon qui refait une application
pour chercher son nom ça m'énerve
Guillaume rosier merci pour pour mesurer
la consommation d'énergie on a
l'impression que c'est l'état c'est un
mammouth pour le coup au sens
préhistorique du terme pas au sens trop
gras et ce qui s'est vraiment lancé dans
cette révolution numérique ou non mais
on a l'impression que il y a un vrai
train de retard et je crois que tout à
l'heure il y avait cette espèce de
comparaison avec la voiture de police
qui doit aller plus vite mais en fait on
est sur ces questions un petit peu comme
dans la lutte antidopage quand est-ce
qu'on sait que Amstrong était dopé et
bah quand il a déjà gagné 7 fois le Tour
de France c'est quand même un petit
problème et donc il y a effectivement on
a on a un problème qui est aussi à mon
sens accentué par nos propres règles
regardez ils veulent équiper les
services de police en matériel
informatique vous imaginez bien qu'un
appel d'oeuf qui porte sur 7 milliards
d'euros il doit avoir une durée très
longue les procédures sont très
compliquées entre le moment où ils vont
passer l'appel d'offre et oui ils vont
avoir le matériel il sera obsolète
sachant que là on a parlé de recrutement
on peut ouvrir des postes il faut
ensuite avoir les candidats c'est à dire
que dans le domaine du numérique c'est
une des particularités l'État n'est
qu'un recruteur comme les autres les
entreprises recrutent les organisations
criminelles recrutent les fournisseurs
de services
peut-être pas celui qui proposera le
meilleur salaire
un élément c'est que souvent dans les
annonces gouvernementales vous vous avez
des perspectives de recrutement tout à
fait intéressantes et louables ce qui
est très intéressant d'avoir le droit de
suite se dire très bien vous avez ouvert
tant de poste combien avez-vous eu de
personnels effectivement parce que la
difficulté c'est d'avoir effectivement
des femmes des hommes à la tête bien
faite sur ces sujets-là pourquoi parce
que face à la l'évolution constante des
modes opératoires des attaquants il faut
avoir des gens qui aient une
compréhension à la fois des sujets
techniques mais également qui restent
policiers gendarmes pour avoir aussi
cette cette colonne vertébrale
régalienne et ça c'est une difficulté
pour l'État qui avant pour un certain
nombre de fonctions étaient en monopole
en clair si vous tiez de travailler sur
un porte-avion bah a priori avec l'État
qui est un porte-avion si vous voyez
remonter les Champs-Élysées à contresens
avec un gyrophare et ben il faut être
policier ou gendarmes et ben dans le
domaine du numérique c'est un recruteur
comme les autres et ça ça oblige à
changer le logiciel c'est le cas de le
dire pour recruter être attractif et
fidéliser les têtes bien faite Damien
bancal est-ce qu'il y a des c'est
peut-être un fantasme mais d'anciens
hackers qui
qui passe au service de grandes
entreprises ou alors de l'État
heureusement d'ailleurs heureusement ça
date pas d'hier les Américains font ça
depuis plus de 20 ans on sait très bien
par exemple aujourd'hui en France qu'il
y a des sociétés sans les citer en tout
cas toutes mais il y a yes weya qui a
ogocha qui emploie ethicales hackers
éthiques qui vont donner un coup de main
leur savoir leur connaissance pour des
sociétés qui veulent et bien auditer
regardez un petit peu ce qui
potentiellement un pirate informatique
pour y passer par là donc du coup c'est
étal hacker sont capables aussi de
donner un coup de main et on voit je
prends l'exemple de la gendarmerie
nationale comme la police nationale
dernièrement ils ont fait et ils ont mis
sur la table et bien des appels d'offres
il recherchent des emplois ils
recherchent des techniciens des
ingénieurs donc des gens qui ne viennent
pas obligatoirement du sérail policier
mais qui ont leur connaissance leur
culture leur éducation oui c'est
indispensable je voyais réagir tout à
l'heure sur la question de de
l'éducation de notre éducation
collective mais
est-ce que ça peut être suffisant pour
se protéger d'une cyberataque c'est quoi
si on doit donner quelques conseils de
base pardon d'être très un peu un peu
simpliste mais vous diriez quoi c'est
simple dans la cybersécurité il faut
être simpliste plus on sera simple dans
la compréhension et plus la grande
majorité de la population pourra
comprendre et se protéger s'informer
c'est sécurisé ça c'est ma phrase depuis
30 ans et bien aujourd'hui c'est
s'éduquer c'est indispensable c'est
comprendre le fonctionnement c'est de
faire appel à des professionnels et
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de gens
doivent comprendre aussi que leur vie
personnelle va obligatoirement impacter
leur vie professionnelle et vice versa
et donc du coup c'est avoir des mails
différents certes pas des centaines mais
au moins dédié aux professions dédiées à
l'administration dédiée à sa passion
dédiée à sa famille mais pareil pour les
mots de passe il y en a marre de répéter
qu'il faut un mot de passe différent
tout le temps mais encore ce matin j'ai
des gens qui sont venus me voir me
contacter en me disant ben écoutez on
vient d'être infiltrés et vous découvrez
qu'ils ont tous le même mot de passe
parce que c'est plus simple parce que le
vendredi à 15 on est déjà en train de
penser au week-end il y a un moment il
faut aussi se prendre par la main dans
votre poche vous avez une clé pour la
voiture pour la maison pour la boîte aux
lettres pour le travail pourquoi sur
Internet vous avez un laissé passer vous
avez un passe-partout
mais alors comment les retient tous les
mots de passe alors après
par exemple propose des études dédiées
sur des outils des coffres forts de mot
de passe c'est déjà une petite brique
supplémentaire voilà après il faut aussi
réfléchir on est dans le monde du HAC on
est dans le monde du Play ça fonctionne
je clique et ça fonctionne les pirates
sont je clique et je vous pirate et bien
réfléchissons plus de 10 secondes pour
réfléchir un mot de passe réfléchir à sa
cybersécurité déjà personnelle c'est
indispensable quelques chiffres le
chiffre du nombre de Français victimes
de de d'un vol de données personnelles
selon la société de cybersécurité
anosway 327 300 français ce serait déjà
fait voler leur donner personnelle
depuis le début de l'année
Christine Dubois Clément c'est sans
doute sous-estimé ça
parce que c'est pas si facile d'avoir
des chiffres fiables sur ces questions
de de cyberattaque alors l'estimation
des chiffres sur les cyberattaxes
problème aussi bien quand vous allez
parler des individus que des entreprises
et pour plusieurs raisons notamment
quand vous êtes une entreprise vous avez
pas forcément envie d'expliquer à vos
différents partis prenants que vous avez
eu une faille de sécurité et que
potentiellement vous les avez eux-mêmes
mis à risque parce que ça a été fait
domino tout à fait notamment quand par
exemple vous êtes un prestataire et que
bah vous avez permis par une faille de
sécurité d'infiltrer quasiment tous vos
clients donc il y a une tendance à ne
pas forcément expliquer ou dire et puis
il y a des attaques qui font preuve
d'une certaine furtivité on en a une qui
a été particulièrement marquante et que
vous mettez du temps avant de découvrir
si on pense par exemple à solar winds
qui a qui a impacté 450 des 500 plus
grosses entreprises américaines donc ça
c'était quoi c'était en fait ça a été
une attaque ce qu'on appelle une supply
shattaque c'est à dire que les hackers
ont infecté un logiciel
que par un prestataire reconnu et bien
sous tout rapport et en fin de compte
quand ils ont fait la mise à jour du
logiciel ce que l'on fait en règle
générale et bien pour des raisons de
sécurité bien ils ont infiltré et ils
ont livré le
logiciel malveillant et c'est un
logiciel qui était particulièrement
furtif et discret qui pouvait rester en
place très longtemps et qui permettait
une énorme captation de données là on
est dans le cadre d'une attaque vraiment
spécifique vraiment travaillé qui
demande plus de travail que ce que l'on
aura sur de la petite criminalité qui
s'est déplacée si vous voulez du monde
du monde physique au monde cyber et qui
va aller un petit peu trouver de la
faille parfois avec chance et avec
opportunité mais vous pouvez avoir aussi
cette problématique là donc l'enjeu il
va être là et vous avez des individus
qui se sont fait aspirer leur donner
sans forcément le savoir tout simplement
parce que vous les avez mis alors là on
a parlé des hôpitaux mais sur d'autres
sites et que ces sites-là se sont fait
simplement braquer l'intérieur
statistiques que vous donniez dans aucun
autre domaine de la vie publique vous
auriez cité une entreprise privée pour
avoir une photographie de la situation
vous auriez cité les chiffres de
l'Observatoire national de la
délinquance et les réponses pénales pour
savoir de cambriolage c'est-à-dire que
l'État est dans votre console à indiquer
que l'État avait demandé dans le cadre
de son texte aux entreprises en leur
disant mais on vous demande maintenant
d'aller porter plainte pourquoi parce
que l'État alors il est pas aveugle mais
il est un peu borgne sur cette affaire
parce que autant les États-Unis ont mis
en place un système de dépôt de plainte
très organisé ce qui fait que l'État
peut assumer des statistiques une
photographie de la situation l'État
français par un retard pris quant à la
mesure du phénomène bah en fait et en
clair là les statistiques c'est comme si
vous demandiez un vendeur de porte
blindée de faire les statistiques sur
les cambriolages il est possible qu'il
vous dise que les cambrioleurs passent
par la porte et jamais par la fenêtre
tandis que s'il vendait des barreaux aux
fenêtres il dirait qu'il passe par la
fenêtre et pas la porte donc ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième c'est que ce
sont les organisations criminelles qui
ont mesuré leur risque en clair c'était
des gens qui avaient une activité
crapuleuse et ont basculé la même
manière que on parlait des années 80 il
y avait des braquages de banque
aujourd'hui on ne braque plus de banques
pourquoi parce que ce n'est plus
rentable c'est pas performant c'est
dangereux c'est coûteux le quantum de
Pen est très élevé donc qu'on fait les
pirates les parents les gangsters ils
ont commencé à attaquer les
distributeurs de billets parce que
c'était mobile les fourgons puis même là
et au final c'est une activité quasiment
qui a disparu parce que l'outil de
sécurité s'est adapté donc là nos
criminels se sont dit bah qu'est-ce que
j'en cours comme peine moindre quels
sont les gains je peux les optimiser et
surtout je peux automatiser des systèmes
c'est à dire que le rançon logiciel qui
est donc c'est là ce le à des grands
success story de ces derniers mois c'est
un expédition automatique de messages
contenant un lien ou une pièce jointe
pas toujours mais globalement infecté le
destinataire va cliquer dessus bon ça ça
demande pas de contribution de la part
de l'attaquant ça automatise le
chiffrement et ça envoie
systématiquement le message d'appel à
négociation ou en tout cas raquette et
donc vous voyez que si le paiement de
manière en crypto monnaie se fait le
pirate en se réveillant le matin regarde
son fameux Wallet son portefeuille et
s'apercevra qu'il est peut-être plus
riche que la veille donc c'est très
attractif et donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
des vrais organisations criminelles je
reste sur la même question et je propose
à Damien bancal de nous répondre c'est
quoi ce sont des groupes des petites des
mini gangs c'est plusieurs personnes qui
se réunissent pour faire tourner le
pardon je suis bossien le plus de de
d'ordinateurs et de logiciels possible
ensemble l'évolution en tout cas elle
est marquante moi ça fait 30 ans que je
suis le sujet et au départ on avait deux
trois personnes à droite à gauche la
fameuse image d'Épinal avec le petit
gars en bouton dans son garage ou sa
cave et de fil en aiguille et j'ai
prendre juste un exemple d'un groupe de
pirates qui s'appelait Rex Mundi il y a
une quinzaine d'années qui faisait déjà
du chantage où ça commençait déjà être
c'était avec un site internet c'était de
la menace voire même téléphonique et
aujourd'hui on va prendre l'exemple de
lobbit 3.0 un ce groupe dont on entend
énormément parler parce qu'il a fait
Corbeil-Essonnes mais depuis il a fait
plus de 200 autres victimes dont une
trentaine de françaises clairement cet
été ils ont clairement expliqué qu'ils
étaient une centaine qu'ils étaient
répartis un petit peu partout qui paye
un service après-vente des graphistes
décodeurs qui peuvent même être payés en
mensualité il y en a même un qui a des
missionné dernièrement il a râlé parce
qu'il avait pas été payé voilà on est
aujourd'hui notre législation parle de
groupe organisé moi aujourd'hui je
parlerai vraiment de groupe mafieux avec
un chef quelque part il peut être en
Belgique en France au Canada il peut
être n'importe où et ensuite comme tout
ça est dématérialisé que tout ça est
dans une un état d'esprit de location
voilà et bien on peut avoir des dizaines
de personnes de n'importe quel espace du
globe qui ne se connaissent même pas qui
ne savent même pas qu'ils travaillent
ensemble et qui sont capables de en tout
cas d'embaucher des millions
d'informations détournées et après que
tes financier pour savoir véritablement
combien il gagne c'est l'heure des
arrestations on prend l'exemple de
sodomie Kobie un autre groupe de
rançonnage qui a été arrêté il y a
quelques mois c'était quand même des
sommiers de billets et des lingots d'or
et d'argent saisie complètement fou
alors on va parler il nous reste un peu
moins de 8 minutes dernier chapitre
consacré à la guerre en Ukraine et à ce
que ça ça change dans est-ce que c'est
une nouvelle ère de de cybercriminalité
qui vient de s'ouvrir et je vous propose
un témoignage enfin en tout cas une
réaction pour commencer celle du Haut
représentant l'Union européenne pour les
affaires étrangères et la politique de
sécurité c'est Joseph Borel évidemment
c'est quelques semaines après l'attaque
russe en Ukraine voilà ce qui nous dit
j'ai reçu une déclaration collective
condamnant une cyberata qui a lieu
depuis le début de l'année contre le
gouvernement ukrainien
et l'important c'est que pour la
première fois au niveau de l'Union
européenne un des portes nous attribuons
7 attaques à un acteur étatique à la
Fédération de Russie voilà la Russie
directement nommée par l'Union
européenne Christine dugouin Clément
est-ce que l'Ukraine aurait pu perdre
cette guerre la veille avant même
l'invasion terrestre parce qu'il y a eu
une attaque informatique de grande
ampleur alors il y en a eu il y en a eu
plusieurs et en fait les attaques
informatiques ont vraiment très
fortement augmenté sur des
infrastructures
ukrainiennes pendant tout le mois de
janvier donc préalablement à au
déclenchement de l'invasion
là on est dans un cas un petit peu
particulier parce que faut quand même
pas oublier que l'Ukraine et en guerre
depuis maintenant 2014 et que elle est
prise avec
des acteurs alors on estime qu'ils sont
associés ou backuper soutenu par l'État
russe depuis cette période-là alors très
souvent sur un volet informationnel
pourquoi est-ce qu'on dit estime ou
soutenu parce qu'on a toujours ces
problèmes et c'est ce que l'on entend là
d'attribution de l'attaque puisqu'il est
difficile de savoir en étant à 100 % sûr
que la taille vient de telle opérateur
et surtout comme on l'a dit vous pouvez
avoir différents à cœur à différents
endroits et d'être sûr que la chaîne de
commandement c'est à dire que le donneur
d'ordre est un état donc c'est ce qui
facilite quelque part cet enjeu là alors
sur le conflit en Ukraine il y a quelque
chose qui était particulièrement
intéressant
c'est que on s'attendait un peu de ce
qu'on appelait le choc et la stupeur
c'est à dire que quasiment le conflit
soit fini par les attaques cyber avant
même d'avoir une approche cinétique
traditionnelle avec tant que véhicule et
arme lourdes et en fin de compte ça a
pas été tant que cela et pour ça on a
plusieurs raisons qui sont mises en
avant et qui sont d'ailleurs encore
sujet de débat au fur et à mesure du
temps on aura les réponses plus en amont
alors l'une étant que finalement il y
aurait une invisibilité de ces attaques
cybers c'est à dire qu'elle serait
difficile à quantifier déjà dans le
cyber vous êtes principalement furtif en
plus quand vous êtes sur des sujets
d'espionnage il est difficile de
quantifier si les données qui ont été
récupérées au niveau de l'espionnage ont
eu une véritable utilité et de la
quantifier sur le terrain militaire donc
c'est pas forcément que mais qu'on
aurait ce principe d'invisibilité une
autre approche serait qui aurait une
forme d'impotence et bah alors ceux qui
utilisent sa terminologie là c'est de
dire et c'est ce que vous regardez quand
vous regardez notamment les attaques qui
sont considérées comme étant liées à la
guerre on en a 450 qui ont été recensés
si on se réfère là encore rapport à une
ONG qui s'appelle le cyber peace
Institute et bien vous allez voir que
majoritairement vous avez du déni de
service donc en fait vous attaquez un
site par énormément de demandes pour le
mettre pour le faire tomber du
dépassement donc de l'information mais
finalement un petit peu du hakanic donc
récupérer des données et les faire fuer
mais que vous avez peu de d'opérations
qu'on va qualifier de cyber armes et une
des raisons que mettent en avant donc
les tenants de l'impotence c'est que
finalement mettre en place des
opérations très ciblées ça prend du
temps parce qu'il faut que vous
connaissiez très bien la surface que
vous allez attaquer c'est failles et que
vous créez un logiciel qui soit en
adéquation donc finalement le rythme
d'une arme cyber extrêmement déployée
serait pas forcément en adéquation avec
le rythme de la guerre c'est du moins ce
que l'on va avoir et puis il y aurait un
deuxième volet sur certains potence
c'est le risque de contagion et
d'escalade pourquoi parce que vous avez
une interconnexion des réseaux et à
partir du moment où vous allez lancer
une attaque bah vous pouvez avoir un
effet de contagion et vous la reprendrez
et puis le deuxième cas pour un effet
boom en effet boomerang et le deuxième
cas pour l'escalade et ben vous allez
avoir exactement le même risque que ce
qu'on appelle du rétro-ingénierie pour
du matériel physique si par exemple je
vais vous attaquer je vous lance une
attaque bon vous allez en subir les
dommages mais après vous allez avoir la
ligne de code donc vous pouvez
complètement regarder comment et
construit ce logiciel et vous pouvez
l'améliorer et la retourner donc vous
avez un risque d'escalade assez
important ce sont les les éléments mis
par les tenants de l'impotence et vous
avez l'immaturité qui explique que
finalement le cyber et est un domaine
encore assez jeune assez récent et que
on ferait face aussi à un vrai problème
qui serait simplement du capacité de
l'intégration du cyber dans l'économie
des forces c'est-à-dire d'avoir des
commandements qui soient qui intègrent
toutes les potentialités du cyber qui
est une stratégie globale
c'est surtout qu'il faut le penser en
échelle avec le reste des opérations
c'est ce qui avait fait dire à des à des
membres du ministère
UK bien dédié que finalement il notait
un manque de stratégie globale dans les
attaques cybers qu'ils avaient pu et
soyez essuyer qu'ils estimaient venir de
la Russie alors il y a eu un soutien des
Américains évidemment très fort mais
lorsqu'ils moi m'a aussi frappé j'ai lu
ça c'est qu'il y avait des des groupes
de hackers qui qui ont pris parti et qui
ont pris parti pour l'Ukraine alors
l'Ukraine le gouvernement ukrainien a
fait un appel est-ce qu'il a fait un
appel ils ont appelé l'ity Army
c'est-à-dire de gens qui pouvaient quel
que soit leur localisation géographique
apporter leur contribution leur
expertise de manière à se coaliser afin
de conduire des opérations offensives à
l'encontre de la de la Russie d'ailleurs
on a même vu un mouvement alors qui
était purement criminel qu'on appelle
compti puisque et Conti était alors de
d'émanation russophone et a voulu
apporter son soutien à la Russie et il
s'avère que parmi les pirates présents
donc ont-ils il y avait des Ukrainiens
et qui donc ont décidé pour fragiliser
l'organisation auquel ils appartenaient
préalablement de dévoiler les noms des
personnes qui participaient à ce groupe
cybercriminel donc vous voyez que c'est
une mouvance résumène très diffuse on
est là dans une une vapeur
d'organisation donc ça c'est compliqué
d'en appréhender les contours les les
composantes la réelle expertise et
surtout la discipline s'il fallait
conduire des actions par contre c'est
une force aujourd'hui en présence et
qu'il faut prendre en compte donc c'est
vrai que aussi bien pour savoir qui est
admis ou ennemi connaître l'efficacité
réelle de leurs actions c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement perturbant par
rapport à des gens qui avaient
l'habitude d'avoir des états majors bien
défini considéré comme des
professionnels répondant à des cahiers
des charges précis c'est pour ça que je
passerai les nouvelles air parce que
s'il y a des on imagine à hacker
poursuivi le lundi parce qu'il attaque
une entreprise privée et puis finalement
et félicité par par l'armée pour avoir
soutenu l'Ukraine le vendredi enfin vous
voyez ce que je veux dire et quelle
expertise sont au Labé effectivement
l'une des choses les plus dures dans ces
questions là c'est d'arriver à remonter
jusqu'au donneur d'ordre en réalité là
dans un conflit de guerre on sait pas
finalement ceux qui se revendiquent
russe est-ce qu'ils sont vraiment russes
et ceux qui se revendiquent rien est-ce
qu'ils sont vraiment Ukrainiens comment
est-ce que la désinformation rentre
là-dedans moi j'ai vécu un truc très
personnel je vous le dis en 30 secondes
allez-y l'année dernière dans une
émission on avait expliqué une opération
de désinformation russe contre Pfizer
une petite agence avait payé des
youtubeurs français pour leur faire dire
dans une vidéo que le vaccin Pfizer
était absolument horrible on fait cette
émission je suis ravi de cette émission
et donc le lendemain matin comme souvent
je veux partager le replay de l'émission
sur mon compte twitter et j'arrive sur
mon compte Twitter qui est totalement
russe je ne peux pas vous dire si
c'était les Russes mais vous me direz
comment est votre compte Twitter demain
Thomas ça c'est une jolie conclusion
c'est comment vous dire que je vais
rentrer chez moi légèrement stressé
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce à ce débat j'ai rappelé
les titres de vos livres la
cybersécurité Nicolas arpajian
collection que sais-je c'est au presse
université universitaire de France
Thomas ils sont anti fake news aux
éditions First et puis je vous remercier
aussi Damien bancal est quand même vous
féliciter pour ce fond d'écran là qui
est absolument magnifique j'ai du mal à
voir mais c'est un dessin animé en soi
et donc je vais peut-être essayer de
m'en inspirer merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce à ce débat
c'était vraiment passionnant je vous
donne rendez-vous demain 18h 22h pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public et puis
l'inviter Dorian Mancini c'était à 8h du
matin dans bonjour chez vous et vous
voyez son portrait
Eric verte ancien ministre membre du
parti Renaissance et questeur à
l'Assemblée nationale belle soirée